Cecile Blilious, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm great.
Thank you for having me.
It's such a pleasure.
Of course. I've been waiting for so long
for us to do this discussion
because you're running impact investments,
both part of Pitango,
but really throughout your whole life
you've been all about impact.
Whether it's working
helping evaluate ADHD through technology
or helping create investment opportunities
within the Arab sector in Israel
through Pitango.
So much to talk about, Cecille.
And I'd love to then
allude the conversation
towards more holistically speaking
about what it means to have an impact
and be an impact entrepreneur
on your side of the table
an impact investor.
But before we do that,
Cecile, who are you? Who's Cecile?
Well, very short.
I was actually born and raised in France.
Came to Israel as a child.
Spent my whole life here
and went through the whole cycle:
education, army, and university, etc.
I've always been an entrepreneur
in everything I did.
And somehow life led me to become
founder and manager
of some startup companies.
Got into the hustle of the dot-com bubble,
in and out.
And after that, was very lucky
to join the Noaber Foundation,
which is a foundation
that focused on the early, early stages
of impact investing,
or what we now call impact investing.
So, I've really done
so many interesting things
and it's been a hell of a ride.
And I try to reinvent myself
every 10 years or so,
so it makes it ...
I love that. I love that.
Let's start with talking about
what is impact investing,
and then maybe we can dive deep
into some of the different projects
you've worked on and are still working on
and always draw back on how that fits
into the bigger picture
of what does impact investing mean.
Sure.
So, first of all, impact investing
has a Wikipedia definition.
It's really the intentional use
of investments in order to create
a positive change to society
or to the environment.
Now, because it's impact investing,
we're talking about financial returns.
Of course, it can be different kinds
of financial returns.
It can be lower or higher.
It can be market trade financial returns.
It could be any asset class
that you could choose.
And really, impact investing
is about everything we do.
What I specialize in
and really care about very much
is impact tech investing,
which is something that still
is very, very much in the, I would say,
in the shadows of impact investing.
Because if you look at
the whole the impact investing market,
you'll see about $715 billion invested
in 2019.
Only two billion out of that are tech.
How is that possible?
I mean, how is that even
Really?
Yes, just think about it.
With all the problems
that we are facing in humanity
and our planet,
with the sustainable development goals
which were designed and defined by the UN,
which really are an opportunity
of about $12 trillion from now until 2030,
how is it possible that we haven't thought
about blending high tech into impact
and blending impact into high tech?
So, really impact investing
is about doing good and doing well
in the most basic sense of the word.
So Cecile, I want to get a misconception
out of the way,
because when we talk about impact
and creating a positive change
in the world, immediately I think
most people draw their mind
into nonprofits, charity work,
donating money to help others.
You don't really think about business
and you don't think
about financial returns,
which is part of the responsibility
of an investor, right?
At the end, you want to see
returns on your investment.
At the same time, you're talking about
making a positive contribution
to the world.
So, give me a little bit of context
as to how these things
don't necessarily have to collide.
Yeah. So first of all, making an impact
is something that is very broad.
Impact is a word in the dictionary.
You can make an impact
by giving money away,
you can make an impact by helping people,
and you don't necessarily have
to blend returns into that.
However, impact investing really means
that you want to blend those two.
And actually when you are creating
a solution to a problem,
you need to look at the problem
in a few different lenses.
One is the business lens, okay.
So, you're creating a product
which is a solution for a product,
for a, sorry, for a problem.
And the solution you're creating
is a business solution.
It has to have a big enough market,
it has to have a big enough opportunity,
and a way to the market
that makes sense with your product.
Next to that,
if you look at the same product
or the same problem
in social and environmental lens,
and you define it by thinking about
who your stakeholders are
and who are the people
you're trying to really serve,
then you can very easily tweak
your product and your business
in a way that is very, very focused.
This way you can really blend the two
in a sense that you don't think about
creating a business solution
and then adding some sort of impact into it
which might be a hurdle
and might not fit what you're doing
or might force you to maybe
hire people you didn't want to hire
or locate yourself in a place
you didn't want to be located.
Instead, it really has to be
within the DNA of the solution
that you're creating.
Now, if you're a tech entrepreneur,
and you see a problem
that you'd like to solve,
and you can see this problem also
as a social problem, and you can understand
who are the people who are going to be
the beneficiaries or the stakeholders
that you're going to serve
through serving, addressing that problem,
then obviously you're going
to be able to blend the two
in a way that maximizes profits
because the more you sell your product,
the more revenues you'll have.
But also, the more people
who use your product,
the more impact you'll make.
So, the integrated approach
is what I'm looking for.
100%. You know one of the things
that I became extremely curious about
as I transitioned to my time
from the IDF towards now, Palo Alto,
and thinking about the things
I want to create is, I thought
there are so many different places
around the world where
a lot of the technology and
a lot of the projects
that I'm seeing people work on
are very focused on the US market,
for example, or
consumer products within Palo Alto.
And I'm thinking ... if
we could only leverage
some of this technology outside
to some developing areas.
For example, helping create sustainability
for a billion people in Africa.
And maybe you're not gonna charge a
$15 a month service fee
for another consumer product,
but if you're able to improve their lives
even a little bit
and have them contribute a little bit
to the product,
you can become just as profitable
as another unicorn in Palo Alto.
And that's definitely something
that I've been thinking about
what types of projects I want to work on.
But Cecile, I want to touch a little bit
on your tangible experiences
that you've had, both as an entrepreneur
and as experience.
Maybe you can draw back
to the company you ran
helping diagnose ADHD and helping that
or through investments in the Arab sector.
All right. So, first of all,
I wasn't the manager.
I was the investor of this company.
And also, with regards to the ... fund,
which was the first fund in Israel
that investing ... entrepreneurs,
that was also, the idea was
to initiate and make it happen
and not necessarily run it.
It's really about disrupting markets.
So, it's really about looking at a problem
in a different lens
and seeing underserved populations
or underserved opportunities.
Take the example of the Palestinian
or the Arabs in Israel who are,
until about 10 years ago,
they were totally excluded
from the high tech sector.
Now, it doesn't mean that
they are not good entrepreneurs
or have amazing ideas or ... the talent
and the ability and the stamina
and everything you need in an entrepreneur
to create really great companies.
However, the paradigm was that
these people are just not part
of the game.
The network isn't there,
the understanding of how
business works isn't there,
the access to capital isn't there.
There's a language barrier,
there's all kinds of stigmas and paradigms
that we needed to break.
Now, having said that,
20% of Israel's population is Arab.
So, how is it
that 20% of the population
does not participate
in that particular high tech sector?
It just doesn't make any sense
when the high tech sector
really needs good people,
good entrepreneurs, good engineers,
people with the ability
to even access markets
that Israel cannot access
like the Arab speaking markets.
So, and there you have it.
The opportunities there,
but nobody's looking at it
because it's too complicated.
It seems that
you won't be able to succeed.
You have this, again,
paradigm in your head
that you might not be able
to communicate well.
But actually, when you drop all of these,
then you can really find
good opportunities.
So, same goes with thinking
about a problem in a different way.
So, the entrepreneurs that created
the ADHD solution looked at the way
that ADHD is being diagnosed
in a totally different way
and just decided to try to pick up
on these computerized tests
that children go through anyway
and think about that in different ways
of how ADHD is actually manifested
in the brain, but also in behavior.
And then blend the two
and come up with a solution that is easy,
easy to implement,
easy to use to screen,
and therefore easy to address,
because it's not a disease.
So we're not talking about treatment;
we're talking about how to help
people with ADHD really achieve the goals
that they're trying to achieve
with the condition that they have,
which is ADHD,
and can really be a huge benefit
and not necessarily a hurdle.
So, it's really about redesigning
your thought process about a problem
or redesigning a solution.
Now, I do want to go back
to your previous assumption.
You talked about Africa
and about developing markets
and how would it be so amazing
if you could just take these technologies
that are applicable in Palo Alto
and just apply them in emerging markets.
And that is absolutely very, very true,
and these are, again,
underserved markets, etc.
But, you're falling into the same paradigm
that people think about
when they think about impact.
Immediately their minds takes them
either to think about philanthropy
or thinking about emerging markets.
But, you know what?
Is there poverty in the US?
Is there inability
to access good education
in the US or in Europe?
Is there a problem of gender equality?
Is there a problem
of equal opportunities in cities?
All these problems exist everywhere.
So, when I think about
an impact entrepreneur
or somebody who comes in
with a solution to a problem,
I don't really care what kind of geography
he's addressing or she's addressing.
Actually, I think that we, as investors,
unless we have a clear focus
on a certain geography or a certain sector,
we shouldn't interfere
with what the entrepreneurs come up with.
And if they think that their market
is based in Germany, then so be it.
If they think their market is in India,
amazing.
But we need to make sure
that the entrepreneurs
understand the problem,
they understand the solution,
they understand their competition,
the market, and they're able
to deliver a solution,
which is tech based in our case,
to address that problem.
So, in a way, you see that
even you are stuck in the same paradigm
of thinking about emerging markets,
and a lot of people are there as well
when looking at the
Sustainable Development Goals,
this beautiful design
of these 17 very colorful designs
of the SDGs.
And immediately people say,
"Oh yes, but this is emerging market.
It's not me."
But that's absolutely not true.
Right. 100%.
And I do have to say that,
my personal thinking process
through this is saying,
Okay, as an entrepreneur,
I want to maximize on the impact
that I create with every hour
that I work, right?
And I'm thinking, of course,
there are lots of issues,
and what's been happening
in the United States and Israel
and all over the world in the past year,
especially Black Lives Matter
and the Me Too movement.
It just brings up
a lot of these inequalities
and a lot of these issues.
But at the end of the day,
I'm thinking if I have a set of skills
that I can leverage
towards building a technology
that can help others,
I want to try and help those that are
as far off from the norm
that I consider as sustainable
and as equal.
And at that point, that was my thinking process,
but I completely, completely agree.
And I'm assuming that
that is also a contributing factor
to why a lot of people
aren't considering too much
going into impact entrepreneurship
because they think,
okay, if impact that means
I have to go to the emerging markets,
but I want to be in Israel
or I want to be in Europe,
so I shouldn't even try.
And Cecile, that brings me
to my next question, which is
how do you personally explain
that such a small fraction
of the funds go towards impact investing?
Or why is there such a small fraction
of impact entrepreneurs
in the tech sphere?
Because I'm completely shocked
by the number that you gave me before.
All right. So, first of all
I think there's much of it
with what you just said,
that people really automatically think
about either philanthropy
or emerging markets or things
that they don't really do
in their daily jobs,
and therefore it's not for them.
But except for that,
when I think about impact,
I think about DNA of an entrepreneur
that's looking at a problem
and is trying to address it.
It's an interesting thing
that a lot of the entrepreneurs
are actually addressing
the Sustainable Development Goals,
only they don't know it.
As a matter of fact,
if you look at Israel as an example.
So Israel has about 6,600 startups
at any given moment. From research
that's been done last year,
about a third of them are actually,
indeed addressing one, at least one
of the Sustainable Development Goals.
Only either they don't know it,
or they don't know what to do about it,
or they don't understand
how that has anything to do
with how they talk about their business.
Or, even worse, they think that
if they're going to be talking
about the problems or the social aspect
of what they're doing,
then their investors
are going to be saying,
"Oh, maybe they're not going
to maximize profits.
Maybe we shouldn't touch it.
Maybe it's philanthropy"
blah, blah, blah.
So, I divide my world into two categories:
one is the impact natives,
and one is the impact migrants.
The impact natives are the ones
who are really born into
It's like natives, Internet natives,
okay? So, it's basically your generation, okay.
It's people who understand it very deeply,
who see the world in a very holistic way,
who understands that actually
when you look at a problem
or anything you do in life,
it's always about everything.
There is no like,
you don't live your life in silos, right?
You don't think to yourself,
okay, now I'm this person who is at home
and then I'm this person goes to work,
and later I'm the person
who goes out with my friends for a beer.
You think about yourself
as one holistic human being, right?
And you do all these things
with the same values
that you carry with you everywhere.
Same when you're a company.
Then if you're a native,
somewhere in your stomach,
it feels that you're doing something
that is good for society
or for the environment,
only you might not know
what to do about it,
and you will need some help of somebody
who will help you verbalize it,
measure it, track it, etc. However,
it's a given, right, you don't think about it.
Impact migrants, on the other hand,
which is the majority of the market,
and I'm talking about investors
and the entrepreneurs
and everything in between,
these are the people
who actually do have something
with the Sustainable Development Goals,
but again, they might not know it
and they might need the support
of an investor or a consultant
or someone who will come to them and say,
"Okay. You know what?
Let's look at your product
with a different lens
and think about the stakeholders
that you're serving
when you're selling your product,
and then blend the two
in a way that's integrated.
And let's see if that's actually
within your DNA and your intention."
And you'll find
that the majority of these people
actually were somehow natives,
only they even didn't know it.
So, with a good process of migration,
you can really migrate them
into understanding what is the impact
that they're going to create,
which sustainable development goals
they can target,
how that is really embedded
into their business in the sense that
when you take their business results
and you look at them
through the stakeholder eyes,
then you can really understand
how that impacts the world.
And of course, measurement is key.
So, if you don't measure,
you obviously don't know what you're doing
and you don't know if you're improving.
And obviously when you measure,
you have to measure the net impact,
so not only the impact
that you're creating,
but also consider the potential
negative impact you're making
and discount it, and understand
if you're not really creating
by helping one, you're actually,
let's save 20 monkeys
and destroy the forest, maybe not.
So, all these things
are need to be considered.
So, at the end of the day,
it's a profession,
and you need some professional help.
But migration is where we can really tap
into the mainstream VCs
and the mainstream entrepreneurs,
and you'll find out very quickly
that these people are totally on board.
And they're on board for various reasons:
one is because they care about it,
but two, is because they want to hire
the best talent, okay.
So, you're not going to be working for a VC
or for a startup that doesn't have that
embedded into what they do.
You're not going to buy their products.
You're not going to invest in them.
So, for whatever reason,
it's going to come
and it's going to come fast, okay?
Just remember that your generation,
the millennials,
are going to be inheriting
$30 trillion in the next decade.
And you do care about these causes,
so I think you're going to make
a big difference.
100%. And it's definitely become
very, very evident that people,
when they're looking to join
different opportunities,
they're not just asking
what is the company doing,
but they're looking for the mission
behind the company.
So, definitely mission driven.
It's definitely something
that I see for myself, 100%,
but also for a lot of my friends,
both from the IDF and from Stanford,
that's something that it's
constantly talking about
how is this making a better impact.
In the last minute or two that we have,
I'd love to understand a little bit better
the work that you're doing
within Pitango now, one of,
I believe Israel's largest
venture capital fund.
You're running impact and sustainability.
Paint me a picture a little bit
of the process that you're working.
So, as you have startups
that are coming to you,
how do you even begin to assess
on a due diligence process
if they're making a positive impact,
and like you're saying, also assessing
the negative impact
they might make inadvertently?
Yeah. So, first of all,
I'm super proud of Pitango
and their decision to embed
and integrate impact metrics.
We call the ESG to SDG Continuum Strategy.
And I think this is
like so innovative and pioneering,
Aad I believe that within a year or two,
everyone else was going to want
to do this because why not.
We're not compromising
any financial returns.
We're going to make, to create
much better companies.
Why wouldn't anybody,
like everybody should do it.
So, how does it actually happen?
First of all, I work with
the existing portfolio companies
of Pitango to think about
how they integrate impact
into what they're already doing.
And I'm talking about
early stage startups,
but also unicorns.
Just to give you an example,
I'm working with Via, which is a unicorn,
that is doing shared riding,
and I'm looking at their business results
and what they actually do
in terms of providing transportation,
which is affordable and accessible,
and how that impacts their stakeholders.
Of course it makes money,
but it also makes an impact.
And we make an analysis,
and we make a measurement.
Next to that, early stage startups,
like even Zapata,
which is a quantum computing company
that is looking at influencing
how material is being developed
and how drug discovery is done.
I mean, just think about the impact,
the positive impact, that can be done
with quantum computing.
Now, with companies
that are approaching us, first of all,
we'd like to have as many
impact native companies
as possible approach us,
which they might not have
before I joined the team
because they might not have thought
that Pitango would be interested.
And then, we are going through
an assessment of thinking about their ESG,
so that's really the baseline,
and do no harm, of course.
Then we try to assess
which are the indicators
in the Sustainable Development Goals
that are relevant to their product
and try to see how that integrates
into our due diligence process.
So, I keep repeating that word
like integration, integration.
It's really about integrating
the impact into the business.
And when we do diligence,
we do the questions together.
Then when we analyze it,
we try to figure out in advance
what is going to be the impact
and what can be
the potential negative impact.
And we talk about it with the companies,
and we try to get them to face it.
Now, it can be something as trivial
as not having enough diversity
in your team.
And it can also be something that says,
"Okay. If I deploy this product,
everybody else is gonna be out of a job."
So, how do we make sure that we take care
of the stakeholders and keep them in mind
and are transparent about our decisions
in a way that really makes
a positive impact.
Cecile, this was just wonderful.
I gained so much inspiration
for myself as an entrepreneur,
and I hope that my friends watching this
and the conversations that will evolve
as a result of this discussion.
I'm very excited
to where things are headed,
and I'm extremely excited
to approach you one day
with hopefully an impact native company
and work together.
But Cecile, before we go,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Yeah. So, you know what?
You asked me in advance
and it's really tough.
But I didn't give you enough time,
so this is not a hard commitment.
... off the top of my head. So number one, I'm a relentless optimist.
I know it's two words,
but it is what it is.
There's a hyphen in there,
so it's one word.
... absolute optimist.
I always believe that things
will work out well.
Number two, I really am a believer.
I believe that people are good,
and they're going to want
to make this change
and make this migration
and that eventually impact
will just go back into the dictionary
as a word and everything we do
is going to have an impact
and a positive one.
So, maybe I'm a little bit naïve
to compliment the believer part,
but that's really who I am.
And the last thing
which I think is critical,
and we should all, I think, adopt it,
is I try to be very, very authentic.
So, I practice what I preach.
I really try my best to be very true
about what I preach to the industry.
And this is something
that without authenticity,
we're going to see
a lot of impact ...
and a lot of marketing usage of impact.
And I think this is a risk
that we can't take.
We have to be authentic
about our intention
and the way that we practice what we do.
In a way, it's a hard thing to do
because you have to be accountable
for what you do all the time,
but this is just part of my DNA.
Cecile, toda raba, thank you so much.
This was just wonderful. Thank you
for being so generous with your time.
I know how busy you are.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you, Michael.
And really be careful
with all these fires and stay healthy.
Take good care,
and let's make a lot, a lot of impact.
100%. Bye bye.